the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today is the day we've all been
waiting for we've come to the last
lecture of our course and it's I think a
rather satisfying lecture today not just
because this is the last one but the
content-wise - today we're going to talk
about uniform convergence of series
remember a series can be viewed as a
sequence of partial sums and
consequently our discussion on uniform
convergence applies here and what we're
going to do you see again it's the same
old story now that we know what the
concept means is there an easy way to
tell when we have the property and I
figure again that this being our last
lecture I should give you some big names
to remember and name-dropping wise I
come to our first concept today which I
call the I don't call it that it's named
the wire Strauss M test the wires roust
em test is a very very convenient method
for determining whether a given series
converges uniformly or not by the way
let me just make one little aside
instead of saying the sequence of
partial sums converges uniformly to the
infinite series we usually abbreviate
that simply by saying the infinite
series is uniformly convergent let me
just say it one more time if I say that
the series is uniformly convergent
that's an abbreviation for saying that
the sequence of partial sums converges
uniformly to the series but any rate let
me now go over the so-called wire
Strauss M tests with you it's a rather
simple test I will give you both the
proof of the test and some applications
of it the test simply says this and this
with the name M test comes from C
because you put an M and over here if I
put a C over here they would probably
call it the wire Strauss C test but the
idea is this suppose that's the series
summation n goes from 1 to infinity
Capital m sub N is a positive convergent
series this is going to be sort of like
the comparison test and that the
absolute value of F sub n of X is less
than or equal to M sub n for each N and
each X in some interval from A to B then
if this condition is obeyed the sequence
of partial sums sum K goes from 1 to N
of F sub K of X converges uniformly to
its limit function namely what we call
the series n goes from 1 to infinity F
sub n of X on the interval from A to B C
in other words if I can get this kind of
a bound on what's going on where these
form the terms of a positive convergent
series then this series converges
uniformly now again let me outline the
proof once again let me remind you all
of these proofs are done rigorously and
also with supplementary wording in the
notes so that you can pick this up again
if you missed the high points in the
lecture you see sort of to prove
convergence in the first place I have to
show what that the sequence of partial
sums can be made to differ from this
limit which I call f of X by as small an
amount as I want just by taking n
sufficiently large and the way I work
this thing is I say ok let's take a look
at this difference well remembering that
another name for f of X is the limit of
this thing as K goes from 1 to infinity
I just substitute this in place of f of
X I then get this and now you see if I
subtract the first n terms from this
infinite series what's left is all the
terms from the n plus first on in other
words that this is in turn equal to the
absolute value of the summation K goes
from n plus 1 to infinity F sub K of X
again don't be upset by the case
replacing the end remember that K is a
dummy variable the hardship would be
that if I use the subscript n over here
I would have a logical contradiction how
can you say n goes from n plus 1 to
infinity n can't equal n plus 1 so I
just changed the subscript here at any
rate if I now invoke the triangle
inequality for absolute
namely that the absolute value of a Sun
is less than or equal to the sum of the
absolute values I then get that the
thing that I'm investigating is less
than or equal to the sum K goes from n
plus 1 to infinity absolute value F sub
K of X now remember what the wire straus
condition was it was that for each K the
absolute value of F sub K of X for all X
in my interval was less than or equal to
M sub K so I can now go from here to
here but what do I know about the series
summation M sub K I know that that's a
positive convergent series in particular
because it's convergent that means that
the tail-end meaning from n plus 1 to
infinity that sum can be made smaller
than any prescribed epsilon smaller than
any given epsilon simply by picking and
sufficiently large C in other words I
can make this difference less than
epsilon for n sufficiently large and
here's the key step since M sub K does
not depend on K I'm sorry since M sub K
does not depend on X this inequality was
done independently of the choice of X
you see in other words not only do I
have that this converges to this but
since this was done independently of the
choice of X this is uniform convergence
and maybe I should write that down
because that's important to remember
that this is independent Lee of X that's
what makes the convergence uniform ok
well let's continue on but I think by
means of an example might come in handy
now I think after you do any of these
abstract things I think a nice example
shows what's coming off very nicely and
so I very creatively call this an
example let's look at the following
series cosine X plus cosine 4x over 4
plus etc cosine N squared X over M
Squared ok where n is the number of the
term over here for example the third
term would be cosine 9 x over 9 etcetera
and I now want us
look at the limit function here see is
this a convergent series is it
absolutely convergent is that uniformly
convergent what is it and here's how the
widest routes M test works we look at
the absolute value of the term making up
this particular series see the absolute
value of cosine N squared X over N
squared now let's take a look at this
since n is a integer N squared is
positive so the absolute value of n
squared is still N squared since the
cosine has to be between minus 1 and 1
the magnitude of the cosine regardless
of the value of N squared X is less than
or equal to 1 in particular then the
absolute value of cosine N squared X
over N squared is less than or equal to
1 over N squared for each N and I might
add and all X because no matter what X
is and no matter what n is cosine N
squared X in magnitude cannot exceed 1
on the other hand we already know in
particular by the integral test that
summation n goes from 1 to infinity or 0
to infinity is a positive convergent
series consequently by the wire straus m
test this series here is uniformly
convergent which again means what that
the sequence of partial sums namely sum
K goes from 1 to N cosine K squared x
over K squared converges uniformly to
summation n goes from 1 to infinity
cosine N squared X over N squared that's
how the test works but now from an
engineering point the more important
question what does it mean how can we
use it well for example let's suppose
that in working some particular applied
problem one had to integrate this
particular series cosine X plus cosine
4x over 4 plus cosine 9x over 9 etcetera
the infinite series from some value 0
from 0 to some value T now here's the
key point and by the way I just write it
this way so to
used to the ominous notation notice that
what looks a little bit ominous here is
just another way of writing out longhand
what the terms inside the parentheses
are the idea is this notice what this
says this says first compute the sum and
then integrate for example we might not
know what limit this some approaches off
we do know it it may be a particularly
complicated thing to write down you see
in other words if we follow the problem
in the order that the operations are
given we must first sum this series and
then integrate it but what have we
already shown we've already shown that
this series is uniformly convergent but
for a uniform convergent series we saw
last time that you can interchange the
order of summation and integration in
other words by uniform convergence what
I can now do is integrate this thing
here term by term see sine X plus sine
4x over 16 just the usual technique of
integration and now you see I can
integrate first and then compute the
limit in other words
I can say look at this integral is just
sine T plus sine 40 over 16 plus etc and
so forth again if you want to see this
from the abstract point of view what I'm
saying is that by uniform convergence I
can switch these two symbols now the
important point is that to integrate
cosine N squared X over N squared
remember n is a constant here this is a
very easy thing to integrate in fact it
comes out to be what sine N squared X
over m to the fourth you see the N
squared comes down to the N to the
fourth and when I evaluate that between
0 and 1 all I wind up with is summation
n goes from 1 to infinity sine N squared
T over N to the fourth and this is a
perfectly good bonafide convergent
series and in real life you see I can
approximate this to any degree of
accuracy that I want just by going out
far enough before I chop off the
remaining terms in other words the
beauty in this case with series is that
when they converge uniformly and you
have to integrate the limit function
you can integrate the individual member
of the sequence first and then take the
limit as n goes to infinity okay so far
so good let's apply this now in
particular to power series and again let
me keep reminding you all of this stuff
is done much more slowly in the
supplementary notes my main reason for
repeating what's in the supplementary
notes is I think this material is both
difficult enough and new enough so that
I think that you should hear parts of it
before you sent out on your own to read
it hopefully my words will sound
familiar to you as you hear them
repeated in the supplementary notes ok
look let's suppose that a power series
summation a and X to the N is M goes
from 0 to infinity converges for the
absolute value of X less than R and let
me pick a couple of values of X X sub 0
and X sub 1 such that X sub 0 in
magnitude is less than X sub 1 and
magnitude which in turn is less than R
in magnitude to give you a hint as to
what I'm going to be driving at I'm
going to try to prove that this series
converges uniformly within R and I'm
going to try to prove it by setting up
the wire straus m test and I'm going to
have to compare this with a positive
convergent series and the positive
convergent series that I have in mind is
going to make use of the fact that the
magnitude of X 0 divided by the
magnitude of X 1 is a positive constant
less than 1 and I'm going to set this
thing up so that I can use the geometric
series on it and if that sounds
confusing let me just go through this
now in slow motion and show you what I'm
driving at here see first of all since X
1 is within the radius of convergence
that means in particular that summation
a n X sub 1 to the N as n goes from 0 to
infinity converges
since this converges in particular the
very first test that we learned in
particular the nth term must go to 0
remember for a convergent series the nth
term goes to 0 now since the limit of a
n X 1 to the nth is 0 that means that
for n large enough this will get smaller
than any positive constant otherwise it
couldn't converge on zero all right
those all I'm saying there I guess is is
if this if this is zero and this is M if
I can't make this thing less than M how
can the limit ever be zero in other
words if these things can't get past
them how could the limit be zero so all
I'm saying is that given a positive M I
can always find an N such that when I go
out far enough in other words when the
subscript n is greater than capital n
the magnitude of a + X 1 to the N is
less than Capital m now the key idea is
this what I'm going to do is look at
summation a and X 0 to the N where X 0
is as given over here and what I'm going
to try to do is set this up for the wire
straus M test and the way I'm going to
do that is as follows I look at the
absolute value of a n X 0 to the N
somehow or other the thing I have
control over is not a n X 0 to the N but
rather a n X 1 to the N and now I use
that very common mathematical trick that
gets us out of all sorts of binds and
that is that since I would like an X 1
to the N over here I just put it in and
then I must cancel it out again in other
words all I do is I rewrite a and X 0 to
the N as a n times x0 over x1 to the N
times X 1 to the N in other words notice
that this just cancels and I have what I
started with over here the point is that
the magnitude of a and X 1 to the N is
less than M we already saw that so what
I do is is I split this thing up
remember the absolute value of a product
is the product of the absolute values so
I write it as what the magnitude of this
times this times the magnitude of x0
over x1 to the N in other words I guess
where I should have over here this is
still an equality this is just rewriting
the the absolute value of a product is
the product of the absolute values
consequently this is the absolute value
of a and x1 to the N times the absolute
value of x0 over x1
and the key point is that the absolute
value of a and X 1 to the N is less than
M for n sufficiently raj in other words
for n sufficiently large the magnitude
of a NX 0 to the N is less than or equal
to this expression here but what is this
expression my claim is that this is the
nth term of a convergent positive series
namely a convergent geometric series I'm
going to show you this in more detail
all I'm saying is observe that the
magnitude of x0 over x1 since X 0 is
less than X 1 in magnitude is a positive
constant less than 1 therefore this is
what this is a geometric series whose
ratio is x0 over x1 in other words as
you pass from the N term to the n plus
first term in each case you just
multiply by x0 over x1 which is a
constant therefore by the Y of straus
and test this given series is uniformly
convergent inside the interval of
convergence you see in other words what
this now means is that we can replace
the condition that the series was
absolutely convergent inside the radius
of convergence by its uniformly
convergent inside the radius of
convergence and now you see the question
is what does that help us do and again
this is left in great detail for the
supplementary notes and the exercises
but I thought that for a finale we
should do a rather nice practical
application in particular a problem that
we've tackled many times we haven't
tackled at all we weren't able to tackle
it but a problem that we used as a
scapegoat many times to show for example
why the first fundamental theorem of
integral calculus was not the cure-all
it was supposed to be for example let me
show you what example I have in mind
I'm thinking of this example find the
area of the region R where R is the
region bounded above by our old friend y
equals e to the minus x squared below by
the x-axis on the left by the y axis and
on the right by the line x equals 1 you
see what we used to say before was what
we know by the definition of a definite
integral that the area of the region R
is the integral from 0 to 1 e to the
minus x squared DX but what we do not
know explicitly is a function G of X for
which G prime of X is e to the minus x
squared remember we could solve this
problem by trapezoidal approximation and
things of this type but to invite you
know we could approximate it but we
couldn't get a good bound on the answer
very conveniently what I thought I'd
like to show you now is how one uses
power series to solve this kind of a
problem if nothing else this one
application should be enough impetus to
show you the power of power series they
are a very very important and powerful
analytical technique let's see how we
can handle this first of all from our
previous material we already know that e
to the U is represented by 1 plus u plus
u squared over 2 factorial plus etcetera
u the N over N factorial etc for all
real numbers u ok we already know that
in particular if I now think of C since
u is generically just the name for any
real number since minus x squared is a
real number also I can replace u by
minus x squared and replacing u by minus
x squared leads to what e to the minus x
squared is 1 minus x squared now minus x
squared squared is X to the fourth over
2 factorial and in general you see when
I replace X u by by minus x squared this
becomes plus or minus X to the 2n over N
factorial and to handle the plus or
minus I simply pull in my sign
alternator that's minus 1 to the nth
power and the reason I use n here rather
than say n plus 1
to keep in mind and in power series this
is called the zeroth term in other words
when n is 0 minus 1 to the 0 would be
positive and I want the first term to be
positive at any rate to make a long
story short shorter another way of
writing this is that e to the minus x
squared is summation n goes from 0 to
infinity minus 1 to the N X to the 2n
over N factorial
consequently since these two are
synonyms to compute the integral from 0
to 1 e to the minus x squared DX I can
replace e to the minus x squared by the
power series which converges to it
uniformly namely I can now write this as
what integral from 0 to 1 summation n
goes from 0 to infinity minus 1 to the N
X to the 2n over N factorial times DX
now notice what this says this says in
the order of the given operations that I
must form the sum of this series first
which is not an easy job and then
integrate that from 0 to 1 but the
beauty is that by the comparison test I
can apply the well by the wire sprouts M
test I know that this converges
uniformly wherever it converges
absolutely I already know that it does
converge absolutely for all real X at
any rate then I now know that uniformly
convergence one of the beauties of the
fact that this is uniformly convergent
is I can interchange the order of
summation and integration which I do
over here but this is crucial let me
make sure i under
you see if there wasn't uniform
convergence here mechanically I can
change the order but I may get a
different answer but since this is
uniformly convergent these are still
synonyms and the beauty is if I just
look at the typical term that I'm trying
to integrate here that's a very easy
thing to integrate namely I just do what
we replace this by an exponent one
larger that's 2n plus 1 divide through
by 2n plus 1 in other words the integral
from 0 to 1 e to the minus x squared DX
is just this particular power series
namely summation n goes from 0 to
infinity minus 1 to the
X to the 2n plus 1 over 2 n plus 1 times
n factorial that must be evaluated
between 0 & 1 since the lower limit
gives me 0 and the upper limit here just
gives me a 1 rewriting this this is just
what summation n goes from 0 to infinity
minus 1 to the N over 2 n plus 1 times n
factorial in other words let's take a
look at this when n is 0 this term is 1
when n is 1 this is minus 1 over what 3
times 1 is 3 when n is 2 this is 5 times
2 factorial which is 10 when n is 3 this
is a minus 1 to the third power which is
minus this is 7 times 3 factorial 7
times 3 factorial is what 7 times 6
which is 42 etc in other words what we
now know is that a sub R is 1 minus 1/3
plus 1/10 minus 142nd and if we keep on
going this way
the next term is 1 over 216 which we can
compute very easily what is this by the
way this is a convergent alternating
series and as you recall from our
learning exercises and some of the
material in our supplementary notes not
only does this thing converge but in
such a case the error is never greater
than the magnitude of the next term so
you see what I can do over here is just
take 1 subtract 1/3 add 1/10 subtract
the 42nd and know that whatever answer I
get when I do this has to be exact to
within no more of an error than 1 over
216 and in fact if I now add on the 1
over 216 I think I get zero point seven
four eight and the next term is going to
be something like 1 over 1300 which
means that this must be correct to
within three decimal places you see and
this is the way the so-called error
function the table of error function is
actually computed now I'm going to end
the material of the course
right at this particular point in other
words I will leave the remaining
applications for the exercises and the
supplementary notes what I would like to
do is to become subjective for a moment
too so if I may and even though this
course is quite different from a regular
classroom course I would like to end it
like a regular classroom course and that
is to make a genuine remark to the
effect that this course has been a
pleasure for me to teach it has been
very enlightening it has been
soul-searching to both plan the lectures
and the supplementary notes and the
learning exercises and I myself to coin
a cliche I'm a much better person for
having gone through all of this many
other people worked hard with me on this
also and in particular I would like to
single out three of my colleagues for
recognition professor Harold Mick Lee
who was the director of the centre my
friend John Fitch who is the manager of
the self-study projects and in
particular was the director of the
lectures and also gave me invaluable
advice in many places as to how to
simplify the lectures and make them more
meaningful and finally my friend Charles
Patton who was our electronics wizard
here and kept everything going from a
technological point of view and gave me
also many valuable pointers now from
your point of view I am hoping that you
two can sit back and feel content now
that the course is over I'm hoping that
this long trip back through calculus
revisited has given you a new insight to
sets functions circular functions
hyperbolic functions differentiation and
integration power series so you can go
back enriched revitalize and tackle the
projects of your choice I hate to see
the course come to an end but in closing
it was my pleasure
and I hope that we will have the
pleasure of getting together again soon
to tackle together part two of calculus
revisited and so until that time so long
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate